I stated earlier that two of
the most important geometric
properties of a vector are its
magnitude and its direction.
These two terms are suggestive of the
mathematical concepts they represent.
The magnitude of a vector refers to
how much movement it quantifies, and
the direction of a vector
refers to where the director's
movement is pointed.
Now let's see how to define
these concepts more formally.
If we think of a vector as an arrow
from one point to another,
the magnitude of the vector is
the length of the arrow, that is,
the distance between
the two points it connects.
To calculate distance,
we can use the Pythagorean formula.
In two dimensions, we can make
a right triangle by taking one leg
to be along the x-axis,
one leg to be along the y-axis, and
the hypotenuse to be the segment
between the two points in question.
The length of the horizontal leg is
the difference between the x-coordinates
of the points, and the length of the
vertical leg is the difference between
the y-coordinates of the points.
Then, by the Pythagorean formula,
the length of the hypotenuse squared
is the sum of the squared
lengths of the legs.
Now let's interpret this
in terms of the vector.
The coordinates of the vector give the
difference between the coordinates of
the points the vector connects,
and the length of the vector
corresponds to the length of
the hypotenuse of the triangle.
So the length of the vector squared
is the sum of the squares
of its coordinates.
In other words, the magnitude of v
is the square root of its x-coordinates
squared plus its y-coordinates squared.
Note that we use the double bars around
a vector as notation for its magnitude.
A generalization of this formula
holds true in higher dimensions too.
If v is a vector in n-dimensional space,
and
we call its coordinates v1, v2,
up through vn, then the magnitude of
v is the square root of the sum of
the squares of its coordinates.
Now, using the notion of magnitude,
we can define the direction of a vector.
Notice that all vectors pointing in the
same direction are scaled versions of
each other.
This vector, v2, is twice
the length of this vector, v1, and
this vector, v3,
is a third of the length of v1.
So, for
each possible direction of vector,
we have a whole class of vectors
pointing in that direction.
So, to define the direction of a vector,
we will choose a canonical or
representative element from each class.
For simplicity, we'll use the vector
of magnitude one from each class.
We'll call these vectors
the unit vectors,
since they each have
a length of one unit each.
The process of finding the unit vector
pointing in the same direction as
a given vector is called normalization.
Normalization has two steps.
If we want to normalize the vector, v,
the first step is to find its magnitude.
The second step is then to
perform a scalar multiplication.
We multiply v by the number
one over the magnitude of v.
This scales the vector up or down,
so that its length becomes one.
So, if we wanted to normalize
the vector, v equals -1, 1,
1, we first find its length.
The magnitude of v equals the square
root of -1 squared, plus 1 squared,
plus 1 squared,
which equals the square root of 3.
Then we multiply v by 1
over the square root of 3.
The resulting vector, u,
would be -1 over the square root of 3,
1 over the square root of 3,
1 over the square root of 3.
We can check that u is actually a unit
vector by computing its magnitude.
In this case, the length of u is the
square root of -1 over square root of 3
squared, plus 1 over square root of
3 squared, plus 1 over square root of
3 squared, which equals the square
root of one-third, plus one-third,
plus one-third, which is the square
root of 1, which is also 1.
Since u has a magnitude of 1,
it is a unit vector.
It is the unit vector pointing
in the same direction as v, so
u is the normalization of v.
I should note one last point.
If all the coordinates of a vector
are zero, we call that vector
the zero vector, denoted as the number
zero with an arrow above it.
The zero vector is a vector
indicating no change.
Note that the magnitude
of the zero vector is 0.
However, what happens if we try
to normalize the zero vector?
We would end up dividing
by a magnitude of 0,
which causes all sorts of problems.
So we simply say that the zero
vector has no normalization.
Another way to interpret this is that
the zero vector has no direction.
Just as it doesn't make sense to ask
which way a stationary car is moving.